cowabunga bay at gibson and galleria and  henderson officially opened today the  water park hosted an event with swag  bags and some fireworks it was really  the perfect day for some fun in the sun  as you can see here we caught up with a  spokesperson for the company to hear  about the latest improvements to the  park for this summer  we have a lot of new things planned new  food and beverage offerings is going to  be our biggest we're going to work on  getting our guests through lines a lot  quicker we have a new all you can drink  all summer long souvenir bottles so  providing faster refills for our guests  without having to wait line is our top  priority  another cowabunga water park set to open  memorial day weekend cowabunga canyon  will now take over wet and wild visitors  will be able to use a season pass to  enter both parks